hi I'm Stacy Kent and I'm Jimmy
Tomlinson and we are here today talking
about our work in collaboration with the
Nobel laureate Kazuo Ishiguro's it's
pure serendipity we discovered that
issue Goro was a fan of our music I was
an enormous fan of his work and so I
wrote and he wrote back and the
friendship started and one day Jim and
ish sort of said we should write a song
for Stacie
he writes lyrics in such a visual style
he paints pictures with words that it
gives me an awful lot of information and
suggestion to fire up my imagination to
create music and moods and melodies
around the woods in a world where
sometimes there's so much separation
there's so much disparate news this is
an establishment that brings the entire
world together and that's so vital
that's so absolutely crucial to asthma
the summer we crossed Europe in the rain
smiles of a summer night Ben Goldacre
bad science that was mine Mornington
Crescent breakfast on the morning train
Sardarji yeah sure guru truth-telling
their resistance ping-pong ping-pong is
really very important to us that's too
long this is word association I'm not
supposed to see this is why I'm bad at
this part of the game but we play very
strangely we drill to music Stacey will
count but to the melody of whatever the
latest song that she's learning is
Dolly's I end up also chinkara so
ping-pong is playfulness
[Music]